hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a South African German
Thriller film called The Lost future
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the movie is set in a
post-apocalyptic world where Modern
civilization is collapsed and humans
have reverted back to the Stone Age many
years ago a deadly disease broke out and
started turning humans into cold-hearted
mutants now this disease can also be
spread through bites and since the
mutants are always hungry for meat 99 of
the human population has been wiped out
leaving them on the verge of Extinction
in the first scene we are shown one of
the remaining tribes which has taken
Refuge inside the gray Rock National
Park the tribe is headed by a wise but
religious man named Yuri he believes
that everything is happening as per
God's will so they shouldn't revolt
against it his son Sivan is a ferocious
Hunter who is respected and envied by
everyone the tribe mostly relies on
leaves and berries but occasionally they
also Feast on small rodents Sivan can't
be that ferocious a hunter then for
safety reasons they have a designated
hunting area nobody is ventured out of
it in years but one day while out
hunting with the other villagers Sivan
notices an animal on the other side so
so for the sake of fresh meat he
convinces his chief father to let him
cross the designated line later as Sivan
and the others Venture deep into the
forest they stumble upon Caleb a skilled
but underappreciated Hunter all of a
sudden they hear an animal's roar coming
from nearby and yurias signs his son the
responsibility of leading the attack
much to Caleb's dismay shortly after the
animal reveals itself to everyone's
horror it is a mutilated sloth that has
grown to become the size of an elephant
the challenge is a difficult one but
with savon's lead the tribe attacks the
sloth and eventually takes it down side
note things like this actually existed
in our history Google megafauna of
Australia thank me later however before
they can celebrate one of the tribe's
men comes running screaming in pain it
turns out that he has been bitten by a
mutant and is slowly and painfully
turning into one himself the man pleads
with Sivan to put him out of his misery
when the boy hesitates to comply his
father steps up and kills the tribesmen
with a sharp spear meanwhile in the
distance a man named Amal is seen
keeping an eye on them afterwards the
tribe returns to the village with their
hunt there we are introduced to
Savannah's hot girlfriend Doral who
despite living in the Stone Age has a
spectacularly good skin routine Caleb
keeps staring at her and it becomes
clear that he is a thing for Doral his
sister Miro is aware of this and she
often teases him for punching above his
weight later Yuri raises concerns about
the mutants slowly closing in on their
Hideout and suggests moving their
settlement elsewhere unfortunately the
tribe Elders reject the idea as they
have lived in the current settlement for
a really long time they appear to be
even more religious than Yuri and
believe that they should leave their
fate in the hands of God however Caleb
who has been ignored and shunned all his
life objects to this decision he says
that the tribe should choose their own
fate and go looking for other survivors
just like his late father Jarrett did it
is then revealed that Jarrett was an
optimist who believed there were other
survivors out there he worked tirelessly
day and night to find them but in the
process he got himself killed dejected
Caleb approaches his sister for advice
but when she two deaths in him he
decides to leave the village and go
looking for other survivors however
before he can get far he encounters a
group of mutants heading towards The
Hideout they have somehow found this
settlement and are looking to kill all
the villagers for food alarmed Caleb
changes his Direction and returns to
help his tribe in the next scene the
mutants eventually reach The Hideout and
start wreaking havoc they attack the
villagers with full force killing many
of them in the process including Chief
Yuri after realizing that they are
outnumbered the village Elders order the
surviving tribes men to seek shelter
inside a cave Miro and the others
managed to enter and block the entrance
with heavy logs to keep the mutants out
however Savon Caleb and Doral are locked
outside completely exposed to the deadly
beasts the three then hide behind a
large Rock and watch the mutants trying
to find a way to enter the cave Sivan
suggests attacking the creatures from
behind but Caleb and dorelle believe
that it's a bad idea so the three leave
the settlement and Venture deep into the
woods to find help after a while when
they stopped to drink water from a river
Caleb brings out a book that his father
had given him as a gift the book is from
the Primitive World I.E the world from
before human civilization collapsed
Caleb reveals that he and Miro can read
because their father had given them
lessons a long time ago this makes them
the only literate people in the entire
Forest no wonder they're looking so good
they've been reading 50 Shades as the
three are engrossed in their
conversation suddenly they come under
attack from a mutant to savon's horror
it is revealed to be his father Yuri who
has been taken over by the infection
Savannah is left paralyzed and he
refuses to attack his father fortunately
the mysterious man from earlier Amal
appears and takes Yuri down he then
Comforts Sivan and reminds him that the
mutant wasn't his father afterwards Amal
checks the Trio's noses to look for any
bleeding he explains that apart from
mutant bites the disease also spreads
through the air the only difference is
that through a bite the transformation
process is much quicker whilst through
the air infection it takes some time
before the disease shows its first
symptom following this Amal shockingly
reveals that he is immune to the
infection thanks to a cure a yellow
powder that is extremely difficult to
obtain he then takes them back home
which is on the other side of a river it
turns out the mutants don't like water
and they can't swim this is why Amal has
been living peacefully all these years
at his home the trio is introduced to
his son and wife the latter is upset
with her husband for bringing home
infected humans but he feels it is worth
the risk as Caleb knows how to read oh
the length Simple Minds will go to to
experience 50 Shades later during launch
Amal reveals how the disease first broke
out it turns out that in the past
several scientists successfully brought
extinct animals back to life however
this also brought a disease that they
couldn't control Amal knows about this
because of his close relationship with
Jarrett Caleb's father after the world
descended into chaos Jarrett using his
ability to read conducted an extensive
research to find a cure for the disease
he was eventually successful but before
he could return to the village with the
yellow powder he was killed by gagan a
ruthless leader of another tribe gagan
then stole the Cure along with its
formula and hid it somewhere inside his
City now Amal wants Caleb to decipher
the formula and use it to create more
Yellow powder and save Humanity he
reveals that although the mutants cannot
be reverted back to humans the ones who
have just been infected can be cured
Caleb and his group immediately agree to
help and so they begin their Journey
towards gagan City elsewhere at The
Hideout the mutants are attempting to
break down the entrance to the cave the
elders begin to accept their fate but
miru the two Hunters Remy and yomack
refuse to give up they start looking for
an alternate exit and come across a
small flooded tunnel with light on the
other side only Miro is small enough to
fit through it so she decides to go
alone however the attempt is
unsuccessful and miru returns with a
bunch of leeches stuck to her body Remy
and jomat quickly help her remove them
and shortly after Miro again tries to
cross the Gap this time using every
ounce of her strength she succeeds in
reaching the other side meanwhile the
other villagers inside the cave start to
show signs of infection as their noses
begin to bleed fearing for their lives
the three Escape through the tunnel
altogether after miru enlarges the
opening on the other end of the tunnel
they find a hole that goes up and leads
them outside the cave suddenly yomack's
nose begins to bleed so they all rush to
climb the hole in an attempt to escape
to their horror the mutants appear there
as well the three quickly retreat but in
the process yomack falls down and breaks
his leg Miro and Remy try to help him up
but he refuses saying that he will only
slow them down so with a heavy heart he
orders the other two to escape while he
sacrifices himself to slow the mutants
down shortly after the mutants stormed
the place and kill yomack but as they
proceed to follow the other two they are
held back by the water on the other side
everyone's condition is worsened and
they are on the verge of turning into
mutants before one of the tribes been
completely transforms miru uses her
Spear and kills him this is going full
world war BC oh Elsewhere on the way to
gagan City Amal Caleb Doral and Savannah
stop near a hill to light a signal fire
atop an old monolith Amal hopes to call
a nearby friendly tribe called the
Brotherhood to their aid unfortunately
finally Wally is up on the monolith some
mutants approached the group below
making them flee the scene in fear after
a while Amal falls down and comes under
attack by the mutants he is almost
finished off but fortunately the
Brotherhood tribe notices his signal and
rescues him Amal then reveals about
Caleb and his potential convincing the
Brotherhood to help him in his mission
on the other hand Savannah and his
friends leave for the city in search of
the yellow powder time is running out as
dorelle also starts to bleed from her
nose revealing that she has been
infected after a while they eventually
come across the city it is a dilapidated
place where people are living under a
strict despotism there the trio
approaches a man and inquires about the
yellow powder but he panics and runs
away determined to find the powder
Savannah runs after the man but the
latter manages to escape later when he
returns he sees his friends being taken
away by gagan's men much to his dismay
shortly after Caleb and dorel finally
come face to face with gagan and his
daughter Giselle by this time dorelle's
condition is rapidly deteriorated so
Caleb demands the powder that was stolen
from his father he tells gagan that
since he can read he can manufacture
more powder in the future this impresses
gagan a bit but he refuses to share the
Cure however he agrees to allow Caleb to
visit Jarrett's library and research the
formula after gagan leaves Savant sneaks
into his house holds Gisele hostage and
demands her to take him to the powder At
first she refuses but when Savon reveals
that her cruel father stole the powder
from them she becomes sympathetic
towards their cause and degrees Gisele
then leads Sivan to a Secret Safe
claiming that it contains the powder she
is sure about it as her dad claims to
inhale a small amount every week however
upon further inspection Savannah Deuces
that the safe doesn't contain the powder
as it hasn't been opened in ages in the
library Caleb finds his father's notes
on how to prepare the yellow powder
unfortunately the writings are so
complex that it will take him weeks to
decipher them at the same time his nose
also starts to bleed he pleads for some
powder so that he could work on the Cure
but gagan refused Jesus suddenly Gisele
arrives and informs him that an intruder
has got a hold of the powder panicking
gagan rushes to inspect and he
inadvertently reveals the actual
location of the powder just then Sivan
ambushes him from behind and knocks him
out after this he inhales a small amount
of the powder curing him of the disease
in the next scene and Gisele rushed to
Doral and rescue her in the neck of time
they then make their way into the
library and use some of the powder to
save Caleb afterwards the trio escapes
while Gisele stays back they head
straight towards their hideout on their
way they come across a perilous rope
Bridge the trio slowly walks through it
but before they can get to the other
side gagan and his men suddenly arrive
and start attacking them sadly Savannah
decides to sacrifice his life as he
believes that Caleb is Humanity's last
hope he bravely fights the enemies for a
while but soon he is overpowered and
killed meanwhile Darrell and Caleb
Escape into the woods where they reunite
with them all after reaching the village
the brotherhood takes on the mutants
while Doral administers the cure to miru
and other villagers saving them in a
neck of time surprisingly gagan has
still not given up on his powder he
follows the group back to their Hideout
and tries to shoot Caleb with a crossbow
but a mall Dives in front of him taking
the shot Furious Caleb hurls a battle ax
at gagan finally killing him in the
aftermath of the devastation Amal
somehow survives and the remaining
villagers slowly rise up to their feet
they are now immune to the deadly
disease it has been plaguing the Earth
since decades the movie ends with Miro
teaching the tribe's children how to
read while Caleb says goodbye to Amal
and dorelle before setting off for the
city to continue his father's work
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching